[Musique]
il ya cinq ans ans de recherches sur le
givrage
c'est ça qui nous attirait beaucoup
c'est un hectare le mans c'est connu je
m'appelle gala des monnaies je m'appelle
alain j'ai à paris nous sommes
professeurs de sciences appliquées
excuse non méthodes de changement d'ère
normalement qu'est ce qu'on regarde aux
rémois toujours ma passion c'était la
recherche et l'enseignement
je voulais aussi être en contact avec
des étudiants et faire la recherche dans
le domaine de givrage part sur le
domaine de givray c'est quand même un
demain qui est très demandé
surtout pour un pays au climat froid
comme canada côté recherche j'aime bien
parce que tous les jours on a un nouveau
défi ça nous motive pour par exemple
trouver la solution
il y avait un poste qu elle qui l'a pris
de façon à les faire comme la question
[Rires]
première fois que je vais visiter ici je
dis c'est que l'art c'est un car postal
ici c'est beau ce magnifique ville de
saguenay c'est une belle et des gens
accueillants chaleureux ici pour la vie
famille l'est c'est sûr que c'est une
région on peut avoir plus de temps avec
les enfants avec avec la famille c'est
une belle ville pour eux pour élever les
enfants
sabrina elle est née à paris en france
mais qui en il est venu au canada
avaient massacré en des enjeux ça reste
quand même toujours avoir des étudiants
en fait plus des efforts des fois aussi
pour les attirer vers nous pour leur
montrer quand même quand pour leur
offrir la recherche quand même assez
évoluée on va étudier ton dos par
exemple à comparer l avantage ici comme
par exemple pour les options dr on a eu
plus étudiant doctorant au niveau n'a
intérêt national ici il donnait les
anciens du budo frais de scolarité ce
qu'on aurait pu en fait même au niveau
des sous tension le gouvernement
s'assure que certaines universités quand
ils ont des réputations un peu plus cela
ils vont attirer encore plus de
subventions alors qu si j'étais la
milice l'aja favorisait quand même des
vérités qui sont comme vous avez dû à
une grandeur moyens pour leur donner
encore plus de chances
[Musique]